all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 56
it's another glorious Sunday we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we got cioud thieves and games as a
service a way out price point
Nintendo nin DS Ubisoft 10 cent and pub
G mobile to discuss so we gonna get
right into it so let's introduce the
four horsemen of gaming those usual
suspects at the round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the howl of the young wolf
magnate Lord how you doing sir not much
man I don't know about difficult game
conker yesterday it had be heated for
about two hours I fought him and he kept
handed me the L blood wounds expansion
so close to beat the red I was spill it
I was like this is it it's over it's
done and they just did like some
backflip kung-fu kick kid that it just
killed me I'm like I'm done okay you
still give you the title cuz you did all
you did the standard blood-borne two
right now that was done already right
yeah I'm gonna streaming together again
I'm gonna beat him and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Dominus this tough love profiler with
daddy himself Bobby Lord sovereign how
you doing sir good semi online profile
this week I got on a little bit
II was I was so appreciative that he was
inside we have nothing less than the
premium experience I am so sorry
oh when I saw these people was blow
faint look at how they move they're
moving so smooth and everything they was
looking like too sloppy we'll slapping
each other
it was the most display of heavyweight
boxing magazine
the nerve to talk about Tilly and white
is ready for Deonte wild Billy if you
stepping in with Deontay Wilder he is
going to put you in the hospital for so
long Showtime
but it's over there sky sky sky network
Skylanders people by putting them in
with bar fights bar Fitness Canelo
getting suspended okay this is my take
on the whole thing right do I believe
that could be controversial with this a
lot of people work for anybody that's in
boxing all right so I can sit there and
tell you exactly what I feel about it
first of all when I saw the kid come
from three different weight classes up
to the we class that he is now anytime
anybody moves up a weight class keeps
their same speed they're boxing part
their power everything stays the same
um you saw that so Canelo and Oscar
asking has been linked to performance
enhancers before right never been caught
out there so we can't Sully his name but
the silliest man with the cocaine and
the process but um that's something
different
this dude now has been found out that he
had clenbuterol
in his bloodstream know plump little
role is something that raises your heart
rate so you can burn more fat as your
training okay so it's like putting on a
wait suit why are you working out so if
you have on a weights too technical and
little role and working out you're gonna
cut up real fast if you let me ask you a
question because I remember I shout out
to a lot of Fonzarelli you know I'm
saying I put you in a new tweet subtweet
as well I was listening to this rush
radio drink they was talking about it
it's talking about I was actually
educated myself I was like what kid go
be proud
I was listening like this children
g-good Canelo J and what they saying
with the Canelo join today there's a
possibility that this may be meat they
say sometimes when they eat some meat or
something you can get in your system but
continue farms that's out there these
animals are being injected with growth
hormone reals severe steroid is very
anything practices that's going on out
there
if you happen to purchase food you may
get tainted meat like we have low levels
of taint in our chicken now so they said
that they found to his samples came back
positive for coming bitter raw now do I
believe it no cuz he could've easily
cleared it up by giving the hair sample
the hair sample is going to give your
last eight years of your history - all
right what have you been taken brother
is going to show up on that's pap smear
was day let this promotion go on there's
too much money to lose so what they're
gonna do is they're gonna show face
what usage that suspension is the
suspension up until April 10th when you
go in front of the board they're gonna
present their case that the meat was
tainted all you have to do to clean your
body is to get dialysis manny pacquiao
used to get dialysis our farm in the
philippines
they cycle out the bad blood with good
blood right before you bout to get
tested so
that way you can't come up positive all
right I just got caught out there yeah
we dumped John Paul Jones in it okay MMA
was really not going on the UFC too much
last night but uh I got a chance to
watch some gal official 41 MMA it has
wild fibro I'm probably gonna retweet it
on my account it's the wildest thing
I've ever seen you know a guy about to
get knocked out you know jumps into the
oven I mean he actually hits the guy
about to drop him jumps to the other
guy's got to finish him off in the
process of going down his knee I mean he
hits the knee of his opponent and knocks
himself out the other dude hits him with
the one-two and you thought it was over
but he decided to jump on this booth
unconscious back and then do like a
freak tuck from a sock so he's an under
investigation right now he tried to he
tried to dislocate that man's law see I
have psycho psycho we talked about that
was the most disgusting display of
unprofessionalism that I've seen all
right the two feet to the head roll to
the Lord but I had to share it with the
Lord's or Lord a decree see I put it in
the um I'll feed chat so yeah I could
check it if y'all want some good
entertainment but of course the shinobi
gaming ninja himself Laura kognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP now telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so let's
get right into what the Lord's our
planners question did you name your
social
the Lord's are playing this week start
off with my man Lord at it what's been
going on I saw you and a kid getting
that stream on man that God made me by
no way out what does that blood-borne
before anyone ask I will be streaming
neo again nice now I got a personal
vendetta that I have to be blood-borne
ok ok
actually I was really getting into the
neo stream and you definitely have my
eye no sovereign love that game for a
long time so yesterday streaming I had
like 15 or 20 people watching me yeah no
one in you know a Playstation tells you
your comments yeah
would there was no comments like for
like I was dying I was like no someone's
talking [ __ ] and then afterwards I was
like I just think I was like maybe
people were just like hating on me in
discord or something I don't know I
looked at my like I looked at the actual
screen like a month old and I had
nothing becomes because like turn your
comments on it wasn't show in the
comments yeah you need that feedback
those type of games are really fun and I
guess a shot you shot small I gotta give
your credits no see that blob for me I
see him going in
I admit those souls games really cool to
watch people stream it's just funny it's
just to see like his rages what bus so I
think blood-borne literally almost
killed him when he be a perfect ball
it's everywhere on Twitter
heatwave I broke you broke Twitter babe
Lord saw came out of the Illuminati this
week to a profile click was online was
that all you were playing this week yeah
see I play a little more of God award 3
gonna get through that before the new
gotta walk comes out on switch I don't
get to play much of anything at all this
week I'm just looking forward to bad
dudes next week arcade on and then yeah
an Xbox man I picked up a way out like
two hours Joseph like okay yeah exactly
perfect and then the discussed I was
talking about
I'm son talk to me what's the show so
soft
listen I'm three years away from this
game right I have not I haven't looked
at it really so to me I'm coming back
and I'm like okay I'm gonna be
everything this new was gonna pop out to
me it's gonna be refreshing right really
oh no no no no no no
I mean to me look the fact first of all
the fact they moved my season mode for
no good reason
yes it took our regular season mode that
you cannot play a regular season mode
with your team with with the constantly
changing rosters during the course that
sees no it's hey hey we got a game for
you it's called 2017 so that that's one
thing they took off the online franchise
I don't care much for franchise mode but
the fact that a lot of people play that
and they got rid of that is kind of nuts
um and the thing is so what they tell
you for the season mode right with the
seasonal is they tell you a hack it's
like alright you go it's a franchise
mode right you turn off all of these
options and then it's pretty much a
season mode and then this series right
there he's like you've got that PSA -
he'll play coming to xbox with April 11
you need to buy end of PSA that's good
I'm buying it again the man Smith's no
4x but continued yeah and then the fact
the actual gameplay is fine like it
always been it's a great plane baseball
game but it's not it's not really change
like the ball mechanics the ball
mechanics still feel floaty mm it just
it just feels and they need to got some
options in terms of hitting like me I
like fairly difficult hitting right
right it was an option that you use the
analog hitting and in the left stick to
aim where you want when ated that part
aspect of the hitting so it's just now
you with the analog stick swinging and
it's a base thing so crazy because me
you have when I'm when I go I'm up my
saber like we have such different
experiences but you've been away from
the game more than I have yeah I've been
away longer the way 3 I probably been
away like 5 I have accomplished over
like five my big beef with it is that it
they changing the game to be more in
line with microtransactions purchases I
oh shut up it's not awesome my
piscatella man love you Matt but you
know I'm not gonna sit there and open a
hundred baseball packs to try to get a
diamond player that's not going down
into month we're moving these two modes
is telling me okay so now they're gonna
charge you $60 a year for what really is
a roster update Wow so they really stuck
in microtransactions and they slap me
it's starting trouble at a chat already
[Laughter]
rockin low-key it's been going on with
you would you be playing besides are no
way out anything else you touch no way
out is Puffy's album it's a way out I
was going to am a Brid of games tested
and playing besides you know pub G and
stuff like that and another friend of me
mine got me to play for at night again
it's not my cup of tea type of game no
matter what this detention is not there
I keep placing top five but detention is
not dead I would like to give a quick
story about my seared eaves impression
which I'm going to that part but the
story about it is I have to blame brat
alright shout out it was a team and we
had I do death yeah there's a super high
dude in a he played the alpha and a beta
right so he has access to all these maps
that nobody has access to right so I'm
like oh let's go with this dude because
we can find treasure so we went out
there and we found
we test great booty right we had great
food his chest gives you 670 gold 500 go
like a lot of money right I didn't know
that some chests give you like 50 gold
that's not nothing but but his chest was
giving you Bodi like we out here right
okay
spoke we get back to the back to the
dock right so we talked the boat out a
little bit was telling me you'll be
careful
okay okay we watch the ship so we go
back to the boat so I swim all the way
to they boat i'm on a boat i kill
everybody on a boat but the problem was
they did so much extensive damage to our
boat day my team was trying to patch it
up and i'm like you shoot a boat it was
like we can't shoot a boat because our
bow it has so much holes we have to
patch it up then these do sort of
respawn them back in and then the music
was playing and i boat some battleship
oh you going to the break you got
whatever the Brig
a little bit um see if these early in
the week shout out to of alekan shut up
to kya baat see we got our galleon on
you know the little stuff on it we get
into that later for us game face stuff
but I have fun I have fun I had a good
time with it and then I'm like I said
lost off mentioned I actually picked up
and they'll be the shows after my five
years off and my experience is a little
different
shout out to my man on shout the Lord
filled it thrill that's my dude man I
actually know one person we used to work
together he came up under me and I T but
um yeah man so I seen him posting get me
high so I was like alright he's a big
Yankee fan man tends to be the robbery
in office talking that mess whatever so
yeah I mean I got the HD always really
cool I'll put that resolution bump all
the way up 2160p now I will say this
soft I don't know if it's me like do you
see like some frame pacing issues it
can't quite handle HD or 4k I big 40 40
40 I haven't done it yet but I see the
same thing so yeah I'm gonna drop it
balance is 1440 and then what does the
paper the highest mode 21 sharp sharper
or CR which is very impressed the game
is outstanding to me again this how I
look at it first of all for the first
time and will be the show got a tutorial
when you first you know I'm saying jump
in so that right there I'm
lovely because they let you pick which
mold you want to start what style you
want to do for the bit for hidden the
baton I mean on fielding pitching and
you know I did my post pitching I have I
did the own API me the thing like it's
so cool how they giving you the options
on that now I will say the season more
thing I didn't know about that's a big
of mission but what I do like for the
people who play baseball games and now
that are old and ain't got time for nine
innings
I like that quick what is it quick
counts yeah basically it's like okay
Reyes is up the bed or this guy's up the
bat and the count was wanting to start
you off in the middle of the count that
want to get like four games in you
should I'm saying like you could just go
you don't have to put that moto and
that's for the people where you already
start the bat I like it I like it both
on pitching I like it boy Anil hit it
because in my thing is it makes you play
different cuz my old man Cespedes is up
but damn I'm in the hole or hey I got a
300 count like do I go to fall asleep do
I do the same thing if you're pitching
you don't say you got the same thing so
I like the presentations they just for
me they gotta come out with a patch or
something with that frame pacing that I
do see it
Wolverine fantastic surprised I put some
pictures up on my Twitter so yeah I
could check it out I don't wanna spoil
it too much but it definitely the end of
wool the blade on the switch threw me
for a loop I did not see that coming and
it was really really fantastic so I
thought that was some DLC stuff you know
talk about
like please y'all like if you got one
play for the switch Xbox whatever the
final stage does something different and
I was like wow didn't see this coming
shout out to Michael hell fully
Illustrated we're gonna get you guys on
the show I'm guaranteeing that that's
gonna happen we're gonna do it man
because I love that title man really
good title so that's what we got and
last week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent announcements by Microsoft
regarding the future of Xbox in its
cloud gaming division how confident are
you that Microsoft stays committed to
the console market the winner at 47% in
a threeway ILP poll was the not
confident group multi-plex Box app is
inbound
was the confident group gaming cloud the
reason is just for added reach and third
place at 17% representing the
shadowlord's of course crackdown 3
equals the power of the cloud group so
let's get right into it what do the
Lord's think about this I'm gonna go
straight the Lord addict this was a hot
topic and the people actually they think
that app is coming what do you think
about this I mean everyone's wrong a lot
[Laughter]
on some don't mean you are you gonna
kool-aid they panicking right now
do they drinking so much of that
kool-aid that they might have to go to
the hospital but it's gonna be an option
it's not gonna be the have all be all
and all like I think it's gonna be an
option just like just like everything
else they're doing right now so yeah
it's coming I don't know what for
mistakes but it's coming any people have
people nervous every pcs so that when
you load up
pc-like you load our windows on your PC
that they sneaking into everybody's
household everybody has it
that app is going to be there it's gonna
probably be the default app for your
video games so that every PC user
instead of going straight to steam will
go straight to that you know the game
pass as a service catch you I think more
than affects us gotcha
it's gonna be very interesting I thought
that was a fun little poll and see what
people thinking about the cloud division
but we gonna get into these topics we
got a lot to talk about so I'm gonna set
this thing off right now this is a this
is let me put it this way y'all to the
laws this is probably one of the hardest
topics I had to actually ponder and
think about and it I want to very
curious about the Lord's with this
because um obviously you'd see a thieves
that's one you know it's a it's probably
the most polarizing game I've seen
probably says destiny one for this
generation in my day one and no man's
crime yes yes that and we gotta talk
about it we gotta talk about it I want
to bring this to the first impressions
for what we've played obviously we know
it's polarizing to I want to talk about
the relation to game pass and then
ultimately the third part of this
question will be does lack of content
concern you games as a service moving
forward so let's get into our
impressions and start my closer to cold
most Lord addict sea of thieves
what is your impressions of the game
it's fun I guess
oh I mean there's just like I enjoyed it
when I play it yesterday another day
before yesterday with my cousin and
because he actually knew what he was
doing he was shooting Pete he was
shooting people out of the cannon
straight onto ships like in the middle
of a vice-like consistently like David
mix one time okay and you know when
you're with someone like that it can be
fun because you're doing stuff you don't
normally wouldn't be able to do but like
at the end of the day it was just like I
haven't put much into this game
and I've already played pretty much all
of this game so they just I think it has
a lot of potential they they fix and
they they keep updating it like they you
and we all know they are and I think it
could be one of the best games that's
out
all right so Joe your thing is
foundation it's there you're having fun
you think that this thing could be
really great with the content they
continue to support that that's what
yeah that's what you had with it yeah I
mean you know it's there's no denying it
that there's a lot of people my friends
is playing it's like this wasn't really
what's gonna help this game is even in
two years from now if this game keeps up
the foundation of good dates it's always
gonna be a streamers best friend mmm
I know a big streamer that I've been
following him since he was small and
he's got like two million subscribers
now mmm and all he's been stream okay
okay all right cool now have you tried
it sighs what a quick question do you
have you tried it solo at all or you
kind of like you and I see it like and
we're just like messing around like
jumping or like being I shot myself out
of the cannon just to see my ship hit a
rock you know let's get the Lord
involved Mosab little King have you guys
touch I've seen no locking cause I'm
gonna get solve in yeah that's all
Jerome what have you touched and if you
have you know what is your impressions
of CDs let's get there first I tried to
get in there day one in the afternoon
and by that time they had shut the
surface off for for new players so I
could he couldn't get in so they were
having those issues at day one so that
was that so I didn't get a chance to
play again until this morning this
morning I jumped in I said let me play a
little bit so I have something to talk
about have an idea what's going on and I
did play a little bit during the beta
beta session so just I had an idea of
what the game is um for me the little
bit that I played by myself now a few
points okay the game is beautiful the
world off your world is beautifully
realized um that card the cartoony look
to it fits it perfectly
um so I think they've done a great job
in crafting a world right um it just
seems like the world is you know a
hundred miles wide and two inches deep
and it just feels like they haven't
given you yeah they haven't given you a
they haven't given you enough to do off
the bat um and I you know and to me
that's what's disappointing a lot of
people I know people go in it and they
tend to blaze stuff and oh they try to
finish stuff and you know within the
first day or two of having it and you
know that it's it's unfair when you play
games that way because your expectations
are higher than a normal player who can
play one or two hours whatever mom I
still feel like content is thin but the
world if you look at the map and you
look at all the places on the map that
are identified the world they've crafted
for you is supposed to be huge I don't
know how much variety there is in that
world but it feels like it's huge so
it's just a matter of creating what they
don't have yet is enough content to get
people you know they don't have
something akin to a raid leave it like a
real raid like they don't have they
don't have multiple tiered on like
quests where you like go do this you got
to get this to get to be able to beat
this thing or something like that
because from what I see all the cosmetic
stuff is just cosmetic and the thing
about it is that it's a first-person
game so you don't even see your own
cosmetics right like you know and so on
so the question of it feels like it has
a little bit of an identity crisis like
one trying to be is it trying to be
pirate destiny more than learning me is
it trying to be just hey it's a pirate
world you just go make your own fun and
then if that's what it is go out there
and make your own fun then there needs
to be more content anchorman clarify
your question all you said um yeah they
do so so just repeat just for I just
wanna put put in the chat woody what do
you mean oh yeah you got a raid and
multi-tiered quests that's what he said
for it I guess he's talking on your
content both things both things you know
they say they got a raid and
multi-tiered quests okay cool so in
terms then what I would say what I
experienced in terms of the actual
gameplay then the gameplay itself is a
little shadow like the story in the UH
the whole issue with the like only
having a limited number of bullets and
stuff
that like so it just feels as like this
this this busy work to get him back and
to and fro but again if they're trying
to create a world that you kind of live
in and you had you and you live this
pirate life then that makes sense right
but I think it just needed more got you
know they won't got you one quick
question before I pass it again
um you saw what about I've been seeing
this uh someone called a rhetoric adjust
people's opinions you know what about
the thought process of that and actually
adding you jumping news to what of the
thought process of all the progression
being linked to cosmetic and what about
like the whole aspect that like saying
for example you trade stuff in nothing
makes your gun better or nothing makes
you know anything from a game place
you're better for your level of
dedication of hours in the game or you
guys okay with that are you cool with it
because it's a balance thing just being
cosmetic where you guys act with
progression once you start talking about
progression it's a different game like
again then his pirate destiny and then
the guns of the game have to be
completely different on G so in in order
to make a game that they want everybody
to be able to come in at any point in
time and feel like they can just jump in
and play and not feel like they're left
out in the cold because they don't have
XY and Z and they can't do this mission
of that mission I get that for the game
trying to be inclusive but at that point
everybody is on an even playing field
then the content has to be there in the
variety in the content and the variety
in the gameplay systems has to be there
so they keep people engaged because if
they're not giving you that grind loop
that other game to give you so it's got
to figure out what it wants to be I know
I'm a tag you 'san I mean I want to get
you on this as far as progression are
you okay would it just be an all
cosmetic cuz your destiny guy serious
they need some kind of progression okay
you can't work towards nothing you can't
work towards making my ship look like
cooler than the next guys like you like
you got a war it could be I just go
ahead go hold back give me that playing
xbox addict come on now I know their
point behind it I know why they did what
they did but like
the end of the day like if you want the
game to flourish and do good for years
to come like you're going I mean make it
like a level system like like black flag
ad where you see the level of a [ __ ]
depending on how much is on that ship
and you just stay away from that [ __ ]
like like I understand their point they
want to make sure everything's fair
across the equal grounds but like name
anything that's fair in life people just
go they already complained about like
people greeted stealing stuff all people
boats they should have kept better cared
they brought us here like I went out I
went out of my little boat by myself
there was nobody around me then all of a
sudden like it looks like it cut off to
the side it was like a cutscene my
cousin has crazy spots that he parks at
these days on between between rocks I
was in the middle of nowhere with nobody
attacking me my ship sank every time I
see someone complaining about someone
came on my ship and took it I see a
little like a little doll crying like I
just don't understand like what made you
think I went on with a real season like
the guy is like dub singer is really
seasoned and I think that's the best
thing for it because I was a complete
novice I didn't know like I guess Chris
Chris Chris played the game brap played
a little bit I don't know too much but
they knew about how to put on the
clothes and stuff like that so I'm in
complete wonderment it was wonderland
for me and to me it felt like they drew
too much at the UM the the player at the
beginning like here's everything figure
it out
yeah I'll get it said that okay good
right so I'm like what what the hell so
at the same time that you're looking
around you have said you needed somebody
to guide you through you needed a
captain
shout out to death for being the captain
making a city spots and he understood
where some of the treasure was so I'm
exploring the island getting bit by
snakes while these guys is the chest and
I'm like okay it's time to go guys and
it felt the game felt so vast to me it
didn't feel like bit by sharp I got I
got actually killed by a shark or making
it to Davy Jones locker was an
incredible experience because it felt
like Pirates of the Caribbean um
did the game you can't come in levelled
up right this is a mix between pub G and
destiny is it's a mix of you get in like
everybody else and you handle it like
everybody else
everything will be cosmetic if you want
to work to getting a nice-looking a
little gun good work to get the nice
look a little good if you want to work
to get the nice sword if you want your
pirate decked out put in the time what
about your pirate got not being
different from anybody else everybody
jumps in and everybody's the same
remember I'm coming from pub G's type of
mentality that you know because you have
people that oh we need loadouts mmm
defeats the purpose of the game purpose
of the game is everybody's the same and
you have to out think the other person
so now you're saying that these people
that are complaining I can't I'll think
the next person because last time I
checked anchorman told us that he had a
little ship that went up a gal gets a
galleon and he stole a stuff and
something
we were straight-up trolls like and what
I was saying he was shooting inside of
cannons I wasn't saying he was shooting
as as I can and so like yep he shot us
out of cannons to steal their treasure
mm we see a port who'd should have
straight onto that ship we would still
their treasure just leave which three of
them over there he will come up beside
us because they you know we've waiting
for them to grab a little bit of
treasure they had go out yeah we would
sit there and look where they had the
treasure he would just flop right beside
us and we would jump out jump on the
ship we probably stole 34 I have like
$22,000 right now Oh Connecticut the
shenanigans ethic I will say that this
should daddy gets on you want to know
the most the craziest stuff people think
they have to kill and win those skull I
live this goes both yeah you don't you
just got to sit there and wait for the
victors to come out and load they ship
you rather I got a jumper this way we
kick this everybody take on the game is
they taking it and a point with of what
they want it to be right and not taking
it for what it is for what they
presented to you okay and then when you
start taking it for what it is and you
start loving for you know playing when
you were young you you went you played
in the sand and you you have fun stop
going in with a critical eye I trying to
point out everything that's wrong with
something and start taking in all the
right stuff that they put there really
did not say to be honest with you I
walked away with it um and Brad can
attest it is I walked away with it not
having anything negative to say about
the game 4k sixty frames per second now
that's on a technical side of it
what what starvin doesn't want you to
hear my TV I forced right right so what
that does when he turns that on it
basically match it gives it maximizes so
it gives you I think all the Lord I mean
this this is the most difficult review
of a game I've ever had to make for my
own personal stuff like to be honest
with myself how do I feel about this
game and it comes down I was thinking
about this song like it comes down to am
i having fun or is it the my friends
making this fun and if I didn't have
these friends I'm playing with is this
game shallow right and it's literally
both things like I really it's both like
this I played it like I said I like on
play was saying play the wait on what
you call it and on it was just so much
fun we would just lose that first let's
get like you said let's get to the
technical side graphically this game is
outstanding like it is beautiful we've
talked ad nauseam about the water right
so we know what the water do and he just
wouldn't eat loaded and you see this
world and you're like wow the
possibilities it's so scenic it so
beautifully you love the art
the art style just gives to it and like
I said 4k HDR mine's only thirty King
I'm sorry but but oh it is beautiful it
is absolutely beautiful
any hour just like wow this is this is a
looker you know I mean got my little emo
what's going on loved all that stuff hit
the sale and then it's the complete
teamwork game right all right yo get the
sales okay you get the [ __ ] okay who's
looking out for the rocks
alright in this constant communication
constant banter love that aspect now the
flip side is again I'm a destiny guy
right so we got there we said okay
alright Falcon what's the first class
alright let's go get these chickens okay
cool
which one red hair okay cool so we're
doing that we having fun the
swashbuckling shenanigans encountering
people you know say kya baat su and i
kind of argue when they're not Highland
we got the cool we're doing all this
okay I know there's other stuff I know
there's other factions but it definitely
felt fetched questi and them my main
concern was just like okay I understand
the interacting with other pirates
that's dope you know doing your
shenanigans grieving people have them
for that you make your own adventure in
a sense so in that sense I would you
looking it is different it's what you
make it however I can see the argument
like you know say so that that's where
I'm like I'm really torn because I do
see both sides to this argument these
really illegitimate s'what it's your
personal spirit because I've seen shout
out the subtle Arab oh man attic
I watched I'll arrest you he said he was
gonna stream home see it these you know
I had to watch bro I miss no I said red
is doin see I was too did this is
must-see TV so jump it up let me see and
I felt his pain because in the beginning
the first five minutes of the game the
game tells you nothing like the other
day
things like your Preston elbow I'm sorry
I'm sorry but but rare and Microsoft
need all rel for that like how do you
know any forms of the poor guy didn't
know what you know what you know what
their thought their logic was don't you
these people played the beta for like
not know where to go he's hit been
begging today he's like chat help me I'm
going to turn this game off
help me what Who am I suppose that's the
next stop we go that's the second part
of this question so it's like felt his
pain attic like the poor he got so angry
he's like you know what forget this
trash and he turn to Friday industry he
was done like it that that level of
energy something as little as not
putting tutorial and not only cost him
solve solid red but anyone who's
potentially watching her string exactly
and then that narrative becomes his
experience becomes a narrative that
narrative then goes off to other people
people like this game is trash you don't
say so it's like I get both sides so now
we're gonna toast you know leak this
into the second part which is the the
content thing so obviously we know it's
been getting some feedback
the Metacritic is all over the place
right now right and then I think I gen
they want they had a comment to the
executive producer leave them Joe on a
knee or something like that can't
pronounce his name and on you know their
basic yeah they based talk about the
Krakken oh absolutely we go go for it go
for the crack and gopher was I'm the
only one that was very very underwhelmed
by this thing
I haven't seen it yet I've seen a little
tentacles
yeah I heard that underneath the water
it ain't Norway nobody like you can't
even jump on people like oh there's
multiple different kinds of Krakens so I
started literally go okay I'm the
promise I literally would out
YouTube started looking up every cry if
you let if slack off it will sink your
[ __ ] real but it's like at the end of
the day like how you gonna have to have
no body like come on man he said that
Craig Duncan when he would Craig the
shout out to take for getting Craig
Duncan aka to game of awesome rare up on
the show great interview if you haven't
seen him please it was fantastic cow
kill did Sam Tobin with the questions as
well he said that God Craig Douglas said
the goal is to make sure you saw the
ship and always knew you know that it'd
be there for other players and he said
that right now the Kraken isn't fully
implemented you can't kill it right now
you know Sam don't agree with that
regardless like how are you going to
like flaunt the Kraken everywhere and do
like it runs like that makes no sense to
me do is they're doing different this
week that's the next question that's
probably how it's going like okay I'm so
amazed that you found the Kraken
okay be honest with you I'm so amazed
that you found one tolerant at all Doug
yeah about I would love to find it rude
you understand what I'm saying like you
found it and you were on underwhelmed
well let me find it and let me see how I
feel about it
b-but then you hear the trolls
what I've noticed a lot about roses
y'all troll we'll check out the game is
secretly you're playing it and enjoying
it so now you're just trolling just for
the sake of being a troll oh you're
financially strapped and it's envy now
we just got back from one of those
little skeleton island things so that
might be a actually I think the majority
of the times I've seen people fight a
Kraken was coming to Skull Island right
the big Skull Island right I actually uh
with in my venture to see multiple
Krakens
I sawed a team of like for like just
grab the ship and abandoned debt quite
oh they they loot and just abandoned
deck because they couldn't do nothing to
it really yeah like it's crazy like I'm
not even joking like if you don't keep
track of where all those tentacles are
what kind of times they're doing it's a
rat like okay so let me jump into the
second part of the question which is
about the contact like I said i Jim they
went in unknown just the executive
producer donating and pretty much heat
it was like look you know what's up with
the content like why is it kind of
lacking so he yeah so pretty much he he
went through that whole song and dance
about you know it's growing world it's
gonna involve you know we're taking
people playing feedback they're gonna
say that you know obviously gonna
release new game no cosmetic stuff but
also new mechanics and stuff as it goes
on and that the games here DS is not
going to be exactly how it was at launch
so I wanna bring this back to the Lord
is that acceptable no um also the other
question vote for for Lord egg who's
ready which is are we allowed to
complain and say well with with the lack
of content when it's a game pass game as
well so con
regardless regardless you still pay for
gamepads it's not like this for this
service is free why I don't even care
the people that have the 14-day trial
they're still trying to get your money
after the 14-day trial like you you it's
like Sam said in the comment section
like the concept art for the kraken
showed a huge fully developed terrifying
monster that's false advertising I'm
sorry like he's ready gagging go go go
go to small claims court was like the
things that they highly it might not
wrong or my true/false was not the
Kraken the thing that they kept going
after and after and when you fight the
whole thing I wanted to do it on
somebody boat and still a booty they
showed us a big diamond that we were
going to i'ma find different Krakens
because I want to get it cracking yeah
cracking when the show show hopefully
they give you a great Kraken and you get
cracking and you gonna love it is not
with you King this is funny
does it have a lack of content for some
for others no it's so much like you
Mizar the mere shell from zone
okay yeah he's deflecting he's he's
bloviating again
listen am I saying is a perfect game I'm
always gonna tell you what floats your
boat don't float mine right so for you
to even say oh no brother just don't
worry about it like I get in the game
control is me climbing on your boat and
running with your booty is the most
hilarious thing to me and that's what
I'm getting awful I'm getting off for
the laugh and the joke if I was slide up
on your boat and I'm acting like I'm
dropping your ink enough staff crack it
is a box y'all like that we're just
saying that was sleazy like you look at
you sitting there like out of all the
people that crying and bitching about it
you're probably the only person that's
going to cracking you know that right
you know everybody that's going along
which you didn't see the cracking notice
right stop second handing your fun so
don't give me second hand is fun I can
listen to him and say Oh for real how
was the Kraken he can tell you what he
did what but me present not these people
just watching it on YouTube now the
Kraken rows have to go over here okay
now there's one over here now there's
one over here Kraken fighter
yo that's your experience you got that
is what I'm trying to tell you I can't
tell you about the cracking because I
see it you got it I didn't go on YouTube
and say let me check out the cracking
because I don't do it you complete me in
the dark - cool - splat upon my boat I
want to take this to wrap my boat
approach right pleading the fifth right
now was to be surprised I know this is
like ya know one you know people that
while blood-borne you know listen you
know people that watch you play
blood-borne and I wish I could you could
do that you could go buy the game and go
play it and figure it out your damn self
but no you're too busy secondhand and
you're fun there's somebody else who's
actually living it having fun God you
shoved in winter so did his crew what
the Kraken it wasn't right so I gotta
get you in on this man this whole
cracking business oh he's the cracking
cracking no sovereign a definitely
bluffin okay is it okay to say this is
the game as it is it's going to evolve
eventually is that acceptable or you
know that coming in so your whole
thing's you expect the game to evolve
anyway right this is a game that we knew
was gonna continue to get content and
evolve right the problem is the problem
is they spent over four years on this
game mm-hmm mater's alphas four years
here in my opinion again let's just go
back to the the quality thing is a
subjective thing you know saying this is
crap above this this other thing that's
ridiculous because this objective thing
was crap - you may not be crap to
somebody else
now the the content thing is a
quantifiable comparable thing yes it
means especially if you paid
pay $10 a game pass to jump in they say
you just pay the $10 for one month to
see what this game is about you feel
you're good with that right it shouldn't
really bother you that it doesn't have
all the content now if you paid 60
upfront you didn't get a game passed you
bought the game $60 my expectation is
not a good can we re shut up to take
last night I don't wanna blow them up
but I will blow him up like he don't
want me to blow him up but I will blow
jumping in parties trust me when I'm
telling you this I was there and
everybody was partying up
they played 12 hours from the date from
sue she was able to play they played
into the morning I came back from work
and he was still playing and he still
just don't do we do we have to
difference like approaches to games now
that comes on game press the game press
expectations and a lot of times I'm here
it's argument that look this is a game
pass game
all the time for its retail price it
shouldn't be that way but the fact of
the matter is that this being the first
game
this being the first game that comes out
of this right now
hold this first party going on game
passing the first one that comes out of
it is the one that this dick causes the
most controversy because it does add to
me it doesn't have the amount of content
it should have damn-fool go by game pass
play the game and a hundred of the games
it's like I don't get it like if you
games and you don't get game game pests
like Oh take it back
get your money back and go play to ten
dollars a play the same game by
Microsoft wait I don't get that logic so
how do you see people finesses
expectation like or damage control right
now
like no expectations because because
[Music]
on the game
no excuse at all in your opinion you are
rewriting my philosophy no this is not
rewriting your this is you do do do here
do you like the sound of this this is
you it goes what matters to me matters
most
hey this is what matters to me I got it
for 10 bucks
[Applause]
beautiful that's the content like he
couldn't just say no this game needs
more you like they came back you felt
that it was a lack of content right
I felt that oh snap is crazy here
because you coming at you Mustaine oh
snap is crazy and you are literally
running on YouTube looking for different
Krakens brother I'm so sorry we approach
Gaming completely different my approach
gaming in wonderment and in love
approach gaming as critical and how you
can find out everything that's wrong
differences between philosophy depend on
my mental because relevance a basically
the question which is what I'm going
with is so for $10 a game past game
should have less expectation in a $60
game you know that like that's not it
that's not it what I'm sayin again no I
don't care if you paid $60 if there's
other ways for you to purchase a game
you got a free $14 day trial and you
played the game kudos to you if you have
game pass and the game happens to
release on game pass and you play the
game even better for you if you went out
and said $60 is the way I could go to
get this game great for you you went in
seeing all your options knowing because
I know a guy who has game passed who
played the beta who played the Alpha who
purchased the game $60 because he wanted
the extra cons playing this game way
longer than you don't go there listen I
didn't play it at all I had the I had
this stuff from fan fest I had all of
that stuff we always playing it I wasn't
playing it you know I didn't play it but
I played it and I loved it so because I
looked at it and I loved it am I wrong
no but here's the question you looked at
it and you don't like how the chrono
you got a judge of the game depending on
how much this game cost when you have
with your cousin shooting you and ships
and it was a lot of people do agree with
addict all right as it stands for you
you're enjoying again you love the game
I get it
my question is price Norman do you feel
right now
there's enough to keep you engaged you
pay 60 for the game or you pay ten
retail price for this game
[Laughter]
60 or you pay 10 it needs more content I
agree with you adding now the thing is
it just you needed more context
specifically at launch to get people
invested because the thing about it is
whether it's in game pass or you pay $60
for it if they don't hook you from the
beginning
it's not gonna matter what the game
looks like in a year it's not gonna
matter so this training simple they
needed more there to get people hooked
and it's not not not in love with the
experience of just being a pirate in and
like a like king says you know stealing
people's booty and with that then you're
gonna find it boring I got a lotta last
question for you for solve and this is
will wrap up that this part and shout
out to Disney cuz he read my mind ok so
basically this comes down to if I'm
having fun right does that equate to the
value right or you know versus the
minimal content argument so that's when
I basically is having fun yeah don't
really care about what anybody else is
talking about right - yo this is fun
like a fully fledged
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there was one the second time my ship
got sunk right there was some dude on
the island just shooting cannonballs no
but I was expecting to see heads like
people around and I was expecting to die
a lot more frequently there was nobody
there that's true
that part right there is true because I
thought that it was literally all over
the place and then when I did see the
ship I was scared to death the other
ship because they were just destroying
our ships Oh King how many people you
could possibly run into in two hours
just say that one ship is what I saw I'm
not lying
like we was doing stuff cuz we saw
mission he's like I said he had these
little golden maps stuff that I've never
seen so I was in amazement of the golden
master he had this stuff right and I was
only able to access this stuff because
of him his level was high the best time
to actually see people is in the bird's
nest with the like at night because I
light up the back of their ships
and we move on yes I'm no addict if you
look at the map right the map has a
bunch of like places that are there are
marked off like name locations have you
been to these locations they look
anything like different are they there
they're all they all look a different
perspective and like you know like
they're definitely not all just one
island they have different islands but
they need I feel like what would help
this game the most is that they had more
NPCs like ships populate the world on
void that you can and get and get there
yeah shout out the rappin and he's like
four years of development should have
more content alright his ding I wanna
finish because we're gonna go on all day
now the thing a blast question about
this topic is not at this is out this is
Microsoft's first game pass game right
this is games as a service to future
shout out to a October to the chat as
well all we concerned you know I'm
saying like would future title safer
exam we know stated Akane's up on deck
right we got other stuff maybe your
crackdown or whatever whatever all we
concerned or is this isolated CTE sting
anybody can jump I think but I think the
perception is gonna be that that's what
it is so the games that follow up like I
said it might have an effect on state
indicate if the follow up have to be
different because if not then this
that's gonna be the narrative like all
all these games that come on the game
paths or like these the shallow
experiences and question is is this game
worth playing right now I think I think
I think it's worth it's fun you have if
you you got a good addicts heart at the
end of the day I feel like this game
would be more beneficial for you to pick
up one like the relevant like the the
same thing of their versions of taking
King comes out because we know this is
gonna happen this game is gonna get
completely redone right and honestly it
to me though it hacks they can't pull a
destiny to like that's with with the
content routes and stuff like they have
to continually update after pull a
fortnight right with its constant
there's something your skin's there's
that's
and either way they need to have Ubisoft
continue this game because they don't
know I wanna know at what point in time
the Microsoft become liars late at what
point in time did they become the kid
that cried wolf that everybody had to
look over and say no this is why I'm
saying because I'm saying it to say they
at what point in time did Microsoft
become a company that always tries to
slick talk you like they said we're
gonna give you all our first party games
inside game pass and then automatically
will started giving them the clone now
why look why why are you doing that what
you can't is trash hey I think not you
got a certain scenario that happened
that would make you question you know
you know it might not be on this kind of
scale but they have kind of low-key lied
to us before commercials every time I
was with you I was with you Laura in his
ad we watched him trailers remember the
fallen hero and a pity they just made it
seem like it was all about that matchup
and that's what story he was a traitor
and it was at what point in time do we
not allow stuff to just happen like see
these came out all right and the next up
to bat is state of decay now what
happens if state of decay is everything
that you talked about with all the extra
stuff riding race the back of content
then people are feel like we're not
we're not criticizing game pass we're
criticized and Siad easy I don't know
this is what I'm trying to say no okay
that's what I'm trying to say is okay
you're saying this we're keeping it
isolated to this you're a different
individual than from what I'm hearing
hmm like I've what a weird parties
because I'm talking about the majority
nobody is okay to say that you're okay
with it and people are saying that
you're damaged controlling and then the
other people are saying that yo I don't
like it so oh I'm a hater that's the
narrative right now in comparing this to
the service and not the game is kind of
devaluing the entire see a thief's game
because you have to literally devalue it
to a service to make it worth playing
that's what I'm listening you see and
you feel that I'm devaluing it but when
I'm telling you like when I played it I
was like oh my god like what I'm saying
is that you're having to compare it to
game pass to feel like you justified
buying it like the way I'm going no no
just you can say you know what it is how
I access the game I I could access the
game for free but I access the game
through game pass it came up that's how
I access the game I only talked about
how I accessed the game
now if game Pass was not around and I
had to access together my purchase in
the game
I want to purchase the game as well but
this is what I games you're saying now
yeah yes because when I play my games I
play on your native coming for you say
you twisting your words right that's on
you did you just say that though no way
other than to play it by purchasing it I
buy the game and i'ma play the game and
we'll have the same experience
like let's say I have the same
experience right so I'll be walking away
telling you oh my god is amazing
now I and braaap can attest to this
braaap is in this chatt now I want Brett
to tell us anytime that we've played
together isn't it ten times better than
playing alone or whatever isn't the
jokes incredible isn't everything
incredible it's a total experience when
you're playing a multiplayer game thanks
alright yes right this type again we
display
gets prep 15 minutes on a sleeve [ __ ]
walk it's amazing to me how people value
their gains right now is valuable by
criticism instead of value by fun and it
allowed me to have such a good time it's
such a short period of time that I
walked away from the game saying I
cannot wait to get back in with a squad
and go chase some more booty like it was
so much fun it left me wanting more
no killing you clean II say yes King all
too and you all two of your hours when I
send you the friend request or the
friend invite to play a game don't
criticize my two hours if your two hours
on Netflix native that's the guy oh this
is just like I said I think this is very
polarizing I don't think anyone is wrong
I think I literally try to look at it
from both perspectives I think being
wrong I think we do gotta hold them to a
standard I do feel like we can't just
get away with the I'm what attic on this
I don't know we begin they didn't
technically why about this game at any
point they've all know it's very upfront
about this
well we gotta put the Sparta on the
spotlight on it have a question mark at
least come see that's what I agree with
that part you call
I want that developer update I want that
weekly content cosmic and even not just
cosmetic I want gameplay mechanics off
but I mean I want other things to do
your say cuz that's the problem with
this thing right people like yo there's
nothing else to do or Lou is not warning
that's the problem I they have the
foundation we know is there people I
having fun we see it you know I'm saying
I don't think those people are damaged
controlling cuz they have fun they legit
having fun you're saying by the end of
the day if we don't hold their feet to
the fire and not just say hey game has
game and oh that's it but we need to see
that that constant what type of content
what they right now they need they need
a road map yes yes yes preach it
we understand that you guys are a little
bit dissatisfied with some of the
content that's not out and you feel like
there should be more we got you here's
the road map exactly exactly because
because a lot that the sentiment is a
lot of things out too old-school Shelton
Brad I see our preach preach the church
is in session
oh you know a lot of people feel these
some of the stuff is mundane is repair
as fun as it is like I said some people
just feel like hey there's other things
to do shout to BG he said he said yeah
go out here farming pigs and chickens
over here cause this game is gonna be
way different year from now you're not
home today and I feel like this game in
a year it's I feel like this game has
the potential to be the top 10 most
played game yeah it's unique it's doing
something that nobody else is doing the
pirate Jean was wide open for them and
the key the hook is that first what
looks beautiful and the cooperative
aspect everybody has a role you got to
do something but it the foundations damn
and it's there like the replayability
that something like I wouldn't say that
it's got a lot of replay abilities and
something like monster on it because you
play the same missions over and over
again to get you know farm for stuff but
like look what happened people stopped
playing monster owner they Capcom
dropped a oh here here's a timed event
with
let's get over a million unique players
we gotta get this Katella burger to show
definitely I know a lot of people
playing CDs on the 14 day trial do they
cancel out for that 14 days that's the
question cold in the chat of anybody
wants it
listen that cold already been already
been cleared up they already got that
hypocrisy put inside the chat that same
person that was talking crap already
cashed it in we got people in the chat
Bay Bay waiting baby you appreciate you
doing that ago but yeah this is a good
one see Athena see how it moved forward
great discussion by the law as the
roundtable was lit the chat was lit
Lauren addict no way out
a way out I want to briefly talk about
the people who's played it I think King
you played it in song so I want to
briefly go over you know non spoiling
which pretty much just talking about the
mechanics
because this game is pretty much a
spoiler I don't want to go over like
with the releases such as this
hell-blade save UK to Kona do you guys
think $60 games is out to the work
question should be because the level of
polish that's on this game the level of
mechanics that's thrown in there me and
Lord Solomon was dumbfounded with what
was put inside because when they told me
was 27 bucks I said what because I got
da access so I said 27 dollars and then
um lost our percent but it's free if I
got if I purchased the game you play
with me it's free I said what so I'm
thinking going in it's gonna be total
crap 327 dollars
dude right there what take a step back
from that because this is the new
mentality and I'm glad you brought this
topic up because our mentality is the
more we spend supposed to equate to how
good the game is gonna be $79 boy
attacked it was $79 worth for content um
to be honest this $27 is well worth it
the only problem is you need a friend to
play you can't play it alone without a
friend that's the only negative that I
got with this game everything else has
been positive like I say I game with
enjoyment and wonderment right and I
gave my games on that sovereign and I
had so much fun we laughed so hard even
when we was messing up and we were
technically afraid at this one point
what we was doing this one thing I
really felt my heart in my butt and I
was like I please don't let us mess this
up because I think this is gonna end
terrible fuss oh but the game and we
halfway through it I guess halfway I
don't know I must have got you like 15
times your stream because that was
hilarious Paul Mike
you know but I'm just saying that game
price-wise thank you thank you so much I
mean price-wise
I think it's magnificently priced value
wise I think it's fantastic value for
what they're giving you and if you and a
buddy go half and a half on this game
$15 a piece you know tax included man
you've really come off and there's a
really good-looking game like sovereign
told me to put it in 60 frames and I put
in the 60 frames at the high resolution
mode home saying yeah I'll have to sit
in the chat I say heaven card it has so
much fun I mean let me jump in real
quick cuz I didn't get a chest panel I
just saw it man and I said first of all
y'all know what Cognito size meaning
gaming ninja I am the coop addict I'm an
addict of coop anything coop I love it
so when I seen it I'm like alright I
remember the guy talking about it
whatever whatever I've ever had my eye
on Mir Vallecano Ione when he announced
it at the gaming Awards or whatever it
was
and then um yeah then I saw a kid smooth
and had it clean it and they got to that
segue it's not too much boilers where
the gods are coming in to check the rule
it was so funny and I just liked the
different levels of cooperative things
in the scene for me well I said okay
this is purchase where they had to they
had to go up that shaft and you gonna do
the funniest thing I have ever seen and
I kept seeing them and it was having
relatives like you people the channels
on your attic ain't got no further be
best I'm not gonna see the game
graphically I look the best there were
some rough things well here boy you know
I think it's passable yeah I think it's
passable I think the game was fun sorry
I know native spoilers I know I
apologize but that scene is just
hilarious but it was a must bonding when
I went to go look I'm like 27 bucks so
that was a goal for me and I like to see
more stuff like that and then with two
addicts question you know I'm saying far
as the 60 oh I think we're at that point
yeah I mean obviously with the game
pasty I think with the content thing you
know I think that's where we at you know
I think I think ultimately you know
we've had stuff like hell-blade out
there you know we've had these games
that are not you know even on what was
it a state of decay right state acacie
technically was a forty dollar game
technically I think the landscape is
changing on on some level in ain't got a
problem but lost I would you would you
felt like there's there's a middle
ground again right before when that when
the EE developers sort of fell off and
it was just triple-a or indie there was
no middle ground so you had you know
very inexpensive games and the top of
line 5999 games and there was always
there was always an association with
that price that the game should be of a
certain quality and not all the met that
standard so with Indies now expanding
and now you know an indie game can mean
a number of different things number of
like you know different budgets and
things like that so now you have that
middle ground again so you have games
like this that is you know it's a story
driven game so when you play it multiple
times the story is the same thing with
this game that's cool is that if you
play it with a different person every
time the experience is different because
so much of the movement is cooperative
that ain't no especially with you know
those scenes that we talked about
it's it the experience is the fun and
the experience gonna be different every
time you play with someone different so
this type of game gets through
playability from that I mean to me I
think the model the model is gonna be
across the board all the way I don't
think only $60 games going away no I
think this is still gonna be a certain
level of game you know whatever a game
it takes five years to develop and has
you know 300 people working on it that's
gonna be a $60 game my hope is that they
stay there which is another conversation
we had in the past or they gotta get
more expensive um I think I think this
this variety and this range of prices is
gonna be the way it is for quite some
time I don't think that's gonna change
got you know Dell and the Lord addict
yes so I know you and you can't get it
poppin what's your thoughts on this on
your own topic in the you know the whole
sex doll thing I think this game
everyone in this chat is pick it up mmm
not even if you even plan on playing
this that's fine you should still pick
it up just to support this kind of brand
because we don't get games like this
often and sometimes when we do get games
like this no one supports them we never
seen anything like in there I mean just
from a consumer standpoint got you guys
like you're talking about a game that
the the developer the game made a video
talking about yeah so when you play with
your friend right see you hadn't copy
the game you see the copy of the game if
this copy the game very rough on him I
did not like me I was telling King the
same thing this is the same guy that
developed brothers a tale of two sons
which is a game much in this vein but
you can't play it by yourself I think
you could only play myself but you
control both characters with different
analog bring that game by all accounts
is amazing I think I own it on three
platforms out there so what's up it is
this I'm gonna play brothers but he like
this concept is something he's been
expanding upon I love it his game so I
love it and I want to jump in too
because shout out to attic we had this
discussion offline which is that I love
the
fact that um you know what he did with
like you said the price point hey only
one person has to own the game and then
yo your friend could jump in the game
you don't even have to only I've never
seen the depth yeah that's yeah I'm
surprised he got that pass yeah oh he
said it he said he was like you know
what he said they have nothing to do
with this they don't get any of the
proceeds they don't get in here there's
no you don't say but shout out to him on
that like cuz I know like I said that's
rare you really see that type of stuff
anyways it almost gets a lot of bad
press all right and they just finished
releasing all the characters on Star
Wars too so it's not behind a paywall
you know listen they're getting that
foot and I know they're the evil empire
because they keep winning and they have
the greatest franchises on certain
aspects but this game is really good and
you should really go support it if you
don't like EA like just like you said
the developer himself said they don't
get any of the proceeds it's probably
going straight to the development house
and the development house needs the
bread I'm gonna pay for the game as soon
as I get off today cuz I played on
sovereign Jang you ain't never seen a
game go quicker to the to the EA axis
game it will be this one because they
don't get something out of this cat yeah
absolutely man and into your point we
talked offline like I want to see more
that stuff like I've missed those you
know the only twos the Double Dragon II
like oh I see in the scene if I see the
buddy co-op evolve into it like into
this man is pretty cool to me the thing
is yeah the the coolest part about it is
that there's you know you're separated
right and you're doing your own thing
and you both each have your window until
you come together right so you know it's
a scene in whatever and in the prison
yard what you're doing your own thing
he's doing his own thing and then
something happens that brings y'all
together but at that point you could
talk to whoever you want you could
exercise you could do other stuff
like that's you know it's just a
different way of thinking about how a
game should play and that's what makes
it so interesting and unique like eggs
nobody's trying this yeah shout out the
busy to chat he said yeah somebody
agrees with King because of the image
but they had last a lot of lasting
impressions in the industry wouldn't
have mine and memos they didn't let old
origin and Ultima Online that's a good
point we got as gamers have balanced
look we don't like everything that they
do don't like everything these games
companies but we tend to not give them
credit you know I'm saying there's a
reason that I'm sorry like a lot of
people think Activision I think EA is a
bigger company in the industry than
Activision like Activision's got a
presence but EA just got the IPS like I
don't really see too much that
Activision be doing besides call of duty
and destiny give it those are the two
big one of the two maybe call it duty
now probably the biggest brand that's
ever been in gaming but at the end of
the day it's like why if they're so big
why didn't they get the Star Wars no
it's like wide it and why don't they
have 1520 des working for them like they
just publish games like they don't even
really help develop games much anymore
mmm-hmm absolutely good topic man tap it
Lord addict Lord soft nin DS who you
think is power in your mobile pub gee
baby you know got at me right and I keep
it on a little hush but a German cloud
gaming phenom group got at me to go out
to Germany and he was dumbfounded and I
said well I'm not going out
the next game so we had the Nintendo the
indie spring showcase showing off the
the new Indies that are coming to the to
the switch some of them old some of them
new some of them are exclusive I'm just
gonna get into the ones the main ones
right a bunch of small games that look a
little weird again yeah with the bomb
chicken chicken bog this year in
particular right I don't have they don't
have Mario you don't have Zelda
so the Indies are even more important to
see than last year because you don't
really know when this is coming at some
point you don't really know what
big-name franchises are coming from
Nintendo this year so the Indies are
important so um let's start with one
that's been on on PC and it's been on
the other consoles which is the Banner
Saga Banner Saga is like an RTS
grid-based RTS but like very story based
a lot of the guys who worked on this
game um are the guys used to be a
Bioware so banner saga one and two holes
so now very well
I own that son that look Anna saga is
fantastic I've never heard that game
when I saw it's like your that's my type
of game like it is the mechanics is it
RTS like what is the gameplay mechanic I
notice cinematics two choices that's
kind of like Mass Effect you I like that
but what is it yes grid-based arthéon's
exporting to me how the sewage visit arc
is on switch right now he's like there's
no school for the developers normal
don't even know how they doing it to be
honest is the German cloud people is the
fact that the game is down to the metal
all right they the fact that it was in
the preview program allowed them to get
so close to the metal on every machine
that they put it on with the coding and
everything that you're gonna get the
most out of it on whatever platform that
you put it on all right so when remember
back in the days it will be a lot of
fluff in between coding and that's when
they was trying to say like developers
are lazy these developers aren't you
know quote-unquote lazy these developers
are they cold down to the metal of the
machine so they're trying to get the
most out of every machine because if you
look at any iteration of this game they
got the most out of whatever platform
that it was on right all right that
means that every game isn't exactly the
same and a code base to the system right
I definitely I'm which one yeah know
that this game will look good on the
switch because they were cold straight
down to the metal yeah I mean I'm still
impressed I mean but that's one has been
I still don't know how they're gonna do
because it's such a persistent online
see like this game is the power point on
consoles how's it being system like is
this part of their online when they
system drop like with the fortnight and
the games of that nature is watch this
game come out running better on the
switch and it does the other consoles I
have a funny feeling he might just
because of and I don't want to jump too
far into calor Kings because he I know
he's got pub G mobile serious everybody
engine they really been refining it it
makes sense that it's gonna run well I
don't think it's gonna be as graphically
obviously not graphically intensive but
they keep refining you know ue4 it's it
should be fired I'm serious you guys
everyone in the chat this game comes out
but early smooth don't look like a
PowerPoint I showed we are boycotting
wild card twice on two different
consoles and with switch gets the clean
version the hope have trial and error
when you have a preview programs and
stuff with our nature the benefit is
later on where the game comes out on
other consoles they already made their
mistakes
so those mistakes are repeated early opt
is yes off with the with the rest of the
ninja the minis that had your banner
saga definitely on my list was one two
and three are gonna be on the [ __ ] and
I'm assuming one two three that's a good
question okay continue hater continue
did you play on xbox did you play no no
fighting plan on that Xbox what makes
you tick down go play it only when you
know Xbox try to front they just
mentioned and a chat you just saw it in
the check well you got you gotta forget
about I have the one that he's referring
to the first one yet he's probably
sitting on his which anyway oh it's a
cousin look mice which is what is the
stand for my TV I'm gonna jump to the
was it really do so luminous remastered
luminescent is again I was big it was
big on the PSP on PlayStation platforms
it did come out so on the PSP how long
ago gotcha
on the Vita as well um II was on xbox360
I believe there is a version of it on
expectation the Tendo finally getting it
this gen gotcha keep going alright then
we got the messenger I talked about the
message the ninjas are in the building
right now the messenger is a ninja is
again if you look at it looks like ninja
gating oh no no he was all over that so
the game starts out my ninja so the cool
thing with this game is it looks like
it's an 8-bit type like action
platformer right this is the thing the
game at Midway and your tours into us no
not even when you end it some Midway the
game just changes to a 16-bit game yes
well the the graphics change right and
then on top of that it's not all this
hype for these games that came out like
a decade the only thing that I'm looking
forward is bomb chicken it's the only
thing and I'm listening I'm looking
forward to it I just probably won't buy
a list it's a trial of it I'm probably
will pay to trial it go buy anything cuz
if you notice I'm never on my switch but
um that's the big titles only but
haven't you noticed every last one of
their games look like it's from like a
hyper version of the regular NES yeah
yeah a lot of it has a goal for that
retro feel like the hero looks yeah for
you so we have the messenger right and
then rounding it out this stuff that I
care about
mark of the ninja remastered I'm a
little tight that it's not a sequel we
haven't gotten a sequel with a lot of
people at claim is one of the best
stealth games ever it's up there
with with with Splinter Cell yes up
there like in terms of pure something
yeah the game place made I saw a demo it
is absolutely amazing the mechanics is
it's definitely like I don't understand
why they call me remaster because the
graphic style of this game it translates
well whatever so I don't know what one
blaze towards the check let's go baby
you already know love this love this
game and it kind of died like it was on
360 and PC never went to PlayStation or
the switch much in all seriousness you
need to play this game thanks yo I'm
talking I'm talking about I'm not being
hyperbolic when I say it's one of the
best stealth games of all time of all
time
no you know I'm not gonna throw out that
like it just like that please
like I said I wish it was oh my god you
guys need anything all I know is that it
has more content for body you can see
the whole body could you show me
gameplay
I quite like that tennis game look
pretty fun killer yeah they said the
tender exit but you know Xbox they just
they're not good at shows your firm
ation I guess I'm a black ride is a 76
which taking walks with it let's move on
alright so I'm confused
yeah alright so we'll be soft after a
lot of years of trying to fight off of a
vendee takeover hostile takeover they
were finally able to do it I guess with
Indy understood that what Ubisoft was
doing to try to hold on to that company
was too much for them to try to buy
enough of the company that too hostile
II take it over so they came to an
agreement with the Guillermo brothers to
sell their stake which at this point is
worth about two billion dollars and they
only spent about a
100 million trying to buy with the
shares that they have so it's a win-win
for everybody right now the most
interesting part about this is that one
of the big companies has invested is in
Ubisoft now that VIN ven DS is selling
off their state is Tencent Tencent and a
beast right now yeah Tencent is the
biggest publisher in terms of revenue in
the world in the world and nobody don't
know about yeah this is a Chinese
company who has who owns Riot Games and
League of Legends hmm they have 40%
stake in epic so fortnight mm-hm
the partner would play unknown to make
to publish the game in China right so on
the PC side publishing and they're also
the ones that created the mobile version
and they're publishing it around the
world yes these guys have their
tentacles in everything right right now
50 cent tensing yeah they are they are
beasts and the thing of the great thing
about them is that they don't they're
content to have their shares they don't
get involved in the business the
database our money they just want to
make money so the thing is now see the
thing with Ubisoft is Ubisoft at the
start of this generation they had some
missteps they had missteps with
Assassin's Creed unity right with the
game not being up to par with also some
of their third screen tech you don't
remember at the time at the beginning of
this generation everything was third
screen experiences you know on your
tablet you can do this you can do that
with the division they tried to do it
with unity to with you knew they had a
lot of loot crate stuff that was kind of
a predatory like you can you can play
the game without it but they tried to
really entice you to do it right and
then they also had missteps with with
the whole watchdogs thing where they
showed you a game at e3 and the game
that you got was not really that game
right so I think with those missteps
they realize look we have to change the
way we approach these games and and the
way we were kind of viewed by our
consumers I think there are at a point
right now if you look at what they've
done with rainbow succeed what they've
done with for honor what they've done
even with
bringing watchdogs backwash selves to
didn't get the credit to deserve but
it's a it's a vastly better game in the
first game right um what they're doing
with Assassin's Creed unity like they
they drop and hit after hit they're
about to drop Far Cry right maybe that
would all the pressure on their back
because of the hostile takeover
exactly it's hard to sort of maintain
your vision when you and you're worried
about somebody taking over your company
the facts so the fact they've been able
to do that right especially with these
games that are online centric the
Rainbow six siege the for honor
lightning Tenten is all about that
tension is all about increasing their
power in China right so why then
partnering with Ubisoft now this is the
opportunity for Ubisoft to bring their
biggest franchise especially their
competitive eSports centric franchises
to China and make them a superpower they
because the thing about it is China's
been open to to the rest of the world in
terms of gaming for now a couple of
years now right you've been a few years
now but it's still been hard it's still
been hard for these companies these
Western companies to make inroads in
China because it's just the type of
games that are being provided there like
China likes eSports China likes and
MOBAs China likes you know competitive
stuff no all of these like Rainbow six
C's for on all these games the division
right all of that stuff lends itself per
person that perfectly to the Chinese
market that doesn't have access to these
games at all so my question you guys is
with what we were talking about before
like the perceived like bad practices of
EA and Activision the stuff would
destiny right receive negativity around
some these big companies with tents and
now being invested in Ubisoft do they
have a chance to take over that
third-party publishing crown worldwide
that mmm no other no other company has
that enrolls into China and China is the
biggest gaming market that's been unfair
by the West for the most part yeah this
this is good stuff I mean I've been
keeping my eye on it I didn't know too
much about it I had to do a little
research but like you were saying you
know what the whole of indie stuff and
now $0.10 jumping on the scene what we
saw
and you know good kudos for them for not
getting hastily taken over didn't say
but on yeah this is a big thing I think
the Chinese market is huge I mean and it
seems like the whole direction with them
is it's big on mobile so I could kind of
see things going that route in that
market you'd understand and you've seen
the success and how fast you know I
don't want to I'm not gonna get on Kings
table because that's next but you know
I'm saying we know what's going on with
these you know these battle royale games
now coming over there you know on the I
I think there's a lot of potential here
and I think an American company to get
over there you gotta have them almost
like a liaison right cuz
you can't just jump right Microsoft just
can't jump in it you know I'm saying
like it's not gonna be received you have
to have that cultural / you know that
understands the market lay is on and get
your company India that's why they do in
these little was that five percent ten
percent type of share deals or whatever
whatever and I think they're free to
play the mobile scene that's what it is
if you would have told me like a year
ago yeah dudes are gonna be playing
fortnight she knows they have full
versions again I mean look where phones
are right now I just got the s9 you know
saying that's not plus it's crazy like
the phones right now was running laps
around certain things you know I'm say
so I can see it I think the market is
there I think the potential is there I
think the growth is there I think will
be soft you know that they've got a ton
of titles I could see a rainbow six
siege I can see I can see a mini
division I can see and and in Chinese
gamers that's how they play you know the
end though in the east the console space
that think about why switches doing so
well right the console space over there
it's more of a culturally it's more of a
confined thing at smaller apartments
people ain't doing console like that
over there yeah I'm saying so
everything's on the go everything's
gonna go PSP was doing go Vita was doing
good switch is killing me now you know
I'm saying not saying PlayStation 4
ain't doing well but that's what it is
so I think I think that's where that's
just my thoughts on it I think they run
with it I really do besides besides the
mobile market like
Moe market is huge and that's and that's
going into king stop Bay that's gonna
something that's gonna permeate
everywhere right so then the littlest
investment day is gonna get you big
gains thing is on the console side is
like I'm saying eSports is big right the
competitive scene over there is really
big right now you have people on pub G
screaming about trying to ban Chinese
players from the server's all the ones
that are cheating on these services so
to bring all those all of those
franchises that have not seen the light
of day over there yet to me it gives
them a big competitive advantage like
you don't see them talking about call of
duty doing numbers in China right you
don't see anybody saying that you know
Destiny's doing numbers in China um this
is a big opportunity for them also
considering the fact that they may not
perceived as the bad guys like Maya is
right and like Activision is they're not
perceived in that way at all it's a big
I could see them this five years before
Vivendi can try to purchase them again
right there yeah it's the whole deal is
they can't buy any stock and Ubisoft for
five years Jen bunney's shout all cool
styled in chat is a Chinese on the
biggest mobile gaming markets in the
world even saying I also Dizzy's on it -
he's like follow Daniel mod on Twitter
lots of Chinese market including $0.10
people people in agreement
Llosa I mean Lord addict anything on
this younger China market get a foothold
inside there everybody's trying to like
you said you need a liaison to get you
in type of thing whoever you know
actually can control that market or get
a lease 40% stake in that market will
definitely see incredible growth
Tencent the company Tencent cen C&T i
think that's what it is yeah that's it
is what it is which we get into next
stop it and you know just how you know
it dis Chinese market man it may got
that share now a newbie saw basically at
it was always about to get taken over
you know then his company was a Vivendi
as I pronounced it I'd like to see the
world burns to shame it in Oh everything
on your table example we before I just
think I think in the next five years
they're gonna get an even bigger step in
Ubisoft I think that little 10% or 5%
that they have right now he is gonna
grow and that's the name you're gonna be
hearing a lot more they again they
they're not a opportu now they're not
obtrusive like they just like they put
their money down and little a that you
rock it's gonna be interesting to see as
their influence increases what kind of
control they want more visto just gonna
be in the background no these guys these
guys are going for the world right now
yeah I'm not playing people now EA
active intent people hain't paying
attention right now
cincin is what it is right now they
coming right there shout out your black
guy tends to try to fly below it's a lot
of stuff going on so on Yemen Lord King
you've been patient wait for this this
is your favorite that's our own mobile
and you know pop G was out in China
China and mobile and other Asian markets
and they just got it over here now I was
a workaround for you to get it up I post
it in the chat and you know people was
able to see it and play it with our new
phones or with the phones that we have
going up to the even iPhone 6 is able to
play strip down low versions of the
games what I'm seeing is now has gaming
on your cell phone
achieve the same level of gaming in your
home and does that translate being that
you know the switch is technically
gaming on a goal does all those games
translate well over to the switch and is
to switch the new beneficiary of the
mobile market expanding hmm so this is
that the end for this switch all these
games that we see running on these
mobile platforms the switch can run
those games just as well if not better
because it's a dedicated machine we're
going to be pub G and fortnight on the
switch because it's already in a mobile
space mmm addict what you do what about
the puck G well that just pop just in
that and yeah in general with these
mobile games and the King's point no you
don't it still add to the mobile gaming
is that those games running in the
mobile space will they be running on the
switch by the end of the year right so
then you see pub G running on a switch
this is this leads again to what I'm
saying about this Nintendo and Microsoft
partnership they already gave these guys
Bojo kazooie for smash brothers like
little things have been you know like
swirling in the water and I'm seeing a
pub G on the mobile does it translate or
is it gonna translate to the switch a
you know if they even make a thought of
going to the switch fortnight is going
to go to this you know speaking of that
I was actually talking to one of my
friends on Xbox Live I think it was
someone from Planet Xbox can't remember
relevant to the conversation though but
I was saying that I think Nintendo needs
I think they need to get for tonight I
think for tonight like automatic oh yeah
I want to jump you know I'm saying I
think they need to make that there go
from like matambi target is yeah I heard
that's what it and I'm gonna get a lot
of flack for this cuz I know this name
is not well-liked so I'm gonna say it
Marcus sellers you know he put that out
earlier listen I'm not questioning the
validity of his sources I know there's a
lot of controversy about this guy a lot
of people feel this guy steals or says
he takes credit I'm just telling you
where I saw it first and I remember him
getting a lot of stuff on Twitter saying
like yo that's BS and then lo and behold
here come fortnight mobile right and
then lo and behold you know saying like
it's basically on every platform and I
agree with you like like it's perfect
for a switch it is perfect into Kings
Point i watch the review of pubsey
mobile and I gotta keep it a stack which
run better than the Xbox version now
granny it's a stripped-down texture
version it's it's old-school
you know place to make the export
version run word fax fax and and and
that's my things like when I see that
there's no reason why I can't go to the
switch there's no reason in my mind you
know I'm saying the only thing will just
be with the exclusivity deal if
Microsoft decide to swoop in and say
look you know this is just what it is
but as far as these mobile get in it
unless I got let's solve Nintendo's
already doing it because there's a
couple of game there's a game out
there's a car game you look like a mini
Forza right code on a switch I was like
what's that and kibosh was like oh yeah
I've been out on mobile and I'm like
what like I don't I'm not in the mobile
scene so I don't know what it is you
know me so at the end of the day again
you bring your bringing these games to
another audience also a Nintendo for the
first time I know that it gives them
crap and everyone's like you know
getting ports these are old stuff no one
cares about but these are new to their
base and that's a ravenous base that bad
stuff up
I can see it I think it's only a matter
of time I think Marcus Ellis is right
and I'm gonna kill for saying his name
but he was the first person that I think
for tonight is an ogre and I think all
this stuff debuts when the online
service comes out that includes Ark that
includes all that stuff shall old parts
have to be perfect to check yeah look
crazy it's it's amazing or mobile
amazing imagine that they snatched as
like that's their platforms choice you
know their platform of choice and they
get an exclusive map called Mushroom
Kingdom and oh they're gonna Nintendo
five already looks like something
absolutely alright I think for tonight
is this year on the switch no Alan this
year I think it's either that's what I'm
saying yes she that's this year I don't
I think we get announcement of that at
probably e3 if not some sort of direct
to something beforehand but yeah
fortnight to me is a foregone conclusion
on the switch I think Lizzie said but
what about them fortnight amiibo store
are you in if I load him with a shotgun
and I can land and blast in your face
yeah we can do that we've always already
come to the assumption that King in
about buying amiibos unless you explain
ah see because ha what may his
experience
you the best part about sinistairs he
ran me through their game and this is
what I talk about you know people
talking crap but they actually dare with
you and then you got me to sit there a
future crap and it sucks because I'm
gonna refute I'm not gonna let you run
with anything we came in third not even
trying I was their body in dudes and he
was down on his knees don't don't don't
get slick that was pubsey skill all day
but the like the last 20 a pub gee and
20 or fortnight are two entirely
different yeah I agree I think I think
the tension in pump Jesus I think that's
just some that's enough that's why as
much of a beast as it is it's not it
doesn't have that appeal to no I agree
because a lot of people they want to
just get in I will be in this so it
could be man but it's like when you can
play everywhere l
it is oh yes think about Xbox sbond play
wha
yeah magic if they do a package you get
the what is the de Tendo live Nintendo
plus online whatever it's called packing
game it's right about that there behind
the paywall on xbox you can play stay
out you play with
yeah and now would be the perfect game
that launched that service man fortnight
how could you resist it how do you blame
you for tonight on a goal with Nintendo
the question you don't look like they
stop and no one doesn't doing anything
okay Jesus did ties with Microsoft right
I mean we don't know what's the deal
we've seen this they've been cross
playing they've been we go back to we go
back to the engine owners and the game
that runs on the engine fortnight
that's epics engine they they have that
running at a premium right now whereas I
mean pub G yeah that version on mobile
runs great but it to bring it to switz I
think the switch would have to be more
of a regular like a console development
right and before that makes it verse I
think for now makes it first
what's that go talk to me you know
they're gonna do what they gonna do
they're going to put they're gonna make
you buy the road fortnight that nobody
plays anymore right and then they're
gonna put battle royale more behind the
amiibo you want to be out do you what do
you wanna be in the in the trenches come
by the amiibo I could see it exclusive
item content I guess I could hear the
voice now on the Nintendo Direct like
fustrating like dude come on man no oh
it's 48 it's funny yo shout-out to Chris
Cobra Lee's like was it a free-to-play
game behind the paywall on xbox yeah
that's an English
do ILP poll this week with the recent
release of sea of beams and the rise of
more games as a service to developers be
held accountable when initial launch
content is considered minimal hey no
games as a service is understood to be
an evolving gate B yes lack of content
makes it an unfinished game or C I don't
care as long as this $10 a game fans
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when it goes up to borrow the Lord's the
horsemen were in the round killing it
today let's get our outros on fellas
Lord adequate can define people find you
[Laughter]
first of all I'd like to thank our
guests Lord addict for coming through
today oh how hard it is Lord sleep me
online this will be online playing a way
out with Lloyd came gotta finish that up
playing more than two hours and I'm
gonna try to sloth ooh
mo be the show me alright being
sovereign or PSN and Xbox Live what the
frame pacing baby I see Lord Giga define
people find you I didn't think that we
know I'm so happy that he even came to
cuz when I saw that he was signed in I
was so ecstatic oh my oh my god you
serious last like four pie Opie's
[Music]
alright you go see us at Gamescom game I
just shot all the way you gonna catch us
that pax we got some stuff that we
working up on that a whole lot of things
for you guys coming up so you catch us
on Twitter Instagram Facebook now listen
when we go to pax we won't be going live
alright so you
be able to catch me on Instagram I open
my Instagram so you guys can like log in
and see the real-time now I'm gonna open
up the Facebook so you guys can see that
the Twitter we're gonna go live there so
we're gonna be having three streaming's
that you can see live and then we also
don't have the 4k content that we're
gonna be putting out for you guys get a
chance to see that stuff you're gonna
catch all the interviews all the amazing
stuff that's gonna be going on we are
working out here we're really working so
trust us we're definitely trying to give
you everything that y'all want to need
and give it give you our weirdo opinions
on this beautiful stuff that we call
gaming no blood addict asleep left the
building can we do our outros my brother
I didn't even know you went to mine yeah
yeah thanks for everyone coming by I'm
gonna be streaming blood-borne some more
today mm-hmm okay I'll beat that uh
Chris called ELISA to chat he said he's
seen a lot of he likes a lot of your
streams definitely funny I I think he's
talking about our kids streams but um
yeah we'll see you know look wig or
whatever his name is he's he's he's
definitely getting under my skin that's
for sure first off he's like a deformed
like horse I don't know what happened
there I I was saying to my stream dude I
feel like everyone from from software
and either mentally like destroyed in
the head or their talk with someone in
an insane asylum when they do these
artwork because whoever made wiggling
should needs to probably be in somewhere
for help but I appreciate everyone
that's came out for everyone that
supported my streams
I'd like 22 people at one point
yesterday watching my stream it seems to
go up more and more
yeah you doing good man you gotta give
some love love watching it like I said
you guys made me calm I mean way out
it's thought kids smooth caliber having
like 500 people watching get killed by
the blood same beast for three hours but
[Laughter]
thank you guys on five CDs y'all was on
fire absolutely love segment be sure you
guys hit the like subscribe all that
good stuff the arm outlets will be going
all your stuff will be going up later
salute to everyone says are still
supporting flashpoint number nine when
he bounces up what does it update one
point one point for coming Tuesday there
was a big one we will see how it goes he
talked about that please check that out
when the iron ore podcast you know and
say and like Lord King said tax is
approaching lots and lots of stuff to
talk about we're gonna have a lot of
things a lot of surprises a lot of stuff
to look out for please follow and
support the Lords on both outlets like I
said the inner circle network you will
be here live with the with the you know
podcast stuff and then for the extra
content check the annual podcast YouTube
channel
make sure you guys support enjoy your
Sunday all that good stuff anybody got
anything else before we get out of here
alright when we out catch everybody
later please